i once went to the most like one of the
most dangerous temples in them
in south japan and you climb up a cliff
face with just like a metal chain
if you let go you just died and i i
didn't realize this until i got halfway
i did it and my hands were like slipping
and like bleeding at the end
but like when i asked we got to the top
and asked ryotaro what the [ __ ] is this
he's like
four people died here last year i was
like why are we climbing up here i was
in jeans
and just like some silly trainers i
could just imagine you climbing it with
this hat on
like a pair of vans and there's like a
shot of ryotaro getting to the cliff
edge and his hand's slipping
and it felt a bit like seeing the lion
king well it's a long lived recruit
i should have done in hindsight it's
revenge wait so how long did you have to
climb up this
took like 15 20 minutes it's quite an
endurance it's quite an endurance but
you know
you don't like have any safety [ __ ]
i don't know i don't know i was trying
to film it on a rucksack i was in jeans
so i couldn't like move my legs past
like 20 degrees
and they're like what this yeah yeah is
a video called japan's most expensive
beef and he joke we have to do this
challenge you didn't even clickbait it
it was just part of another club
that's dedication we've got to do a
challenge we'll eat the beef i was like
no we don't we just eat some [ __ ]
[ __ ]
and then he took me there nearly died
and i was like trying to eat the beef
and shake it
ptsd from this cliff shocked
how'd you get down you gotta go down you
gotta go down at the same [ __ ] way
you walk all holding onto the chain just
slipping down
how vertical is this thing [ __ ] so
it's like a footpath it's like the light
is like the lion king if you see the
lion king it's like that no way you can
climb a
vertical wall it was it was it was
almost practically vertical
i love how connor's not like you know
suspicious about
the story he's suspicious about your
athletic ability
him with a camera no way was this like
during the first journey across japan
kind of era where you had to keep in
shape i suppose
before that actually yeah i
if i'd known how dangerous it was i
would have been like no this isn't even
funny this isn't like entertainment this
is just death he didn't even click later
so it was it wasn't
it wasn't in japan how did you not take
one look at it and go like
no that looks dangerous i don't know why
did it take you up until
halfway where you were like this might
be dangerous we had this experienced
climber who's wearing like the most
expensive climbing boots he sort of went
up it really quick
i thought it can't be that hard and then
i got him outside and i'm like
holding onto this chain and you know if
you hold on to a metal chain you just
slip down it yeah your hands are greasy
yeah you start to bleed
and it's yeah that it was just awful
really awful for the content dreadful
god for someone who's afraid of danger
you've done you've been in a lot of
dangerous situations
i want more you could do that but not
not go in a [ __ ] cave yeah yeah
[ __ ] okay i want more
i want to see chris do snowboarding
honestly chris do like the sasuke
challenge
like the [ __ ] like the ninja
like the vertical wall sasuke challenge
yeah it's called sasuke
in japanese oh it's called the sasuke
they just called it the ninja warrior
challenge
in a broad japan wheelchair challenge
but i'm done with it
i don't think so i wrote last night
yeah did you just imagine how funny
would be chris trying to go up the
vertical wall it's a trash taste video
you should go to the [ __ ] cliff and
climb it
i'm down the trash today special i know
we could actually die in this
yeah i think the view's gone why not do
a skiing special but i don't know how
you'd film it be too hard
go pros all round
the challenge is try to learn how to
snowboard which would be my channel
that's true because i've been on my ass
most likely chris to join you guys